네. 안녕하세요. 빌사남의 노크
김요수입니다. 어, 제가 오늘 특별한
게스트분을 모셨는데 저희 김찬호
팀장님을 모셨습니다.
빌사남의 노크.
네, 안녕하세요. 저는 도산대로 빌딩
씨라는 유튜브 채널을 운영하고 있는
빌사남의 김찬호 팀장입니다. 그
요즘에 그런 질문들 되게 많더라고요.
강남 쪽에서 제일 유명한 데가 이제
강남역이고. 음. 그죠. 그리고
최근에 이제 개발 호재들이 많은
삼성력이 있는데 그 두 개 중에 어디
투자하는게 좋을까라는 질문들이 좀
많아서 팀장님이랑 좀 얘기를 해
보려고 하는데 어디가 좋은 거
같으세요? 성격 자체가 많이 다른 거
같아요. 그게 좀 한마디로 정리를
하자면은 강남역은 뭔가 그 현재
가치가 굉장히 좀 탄탄하다라고 좀
느낌을 받고 있고요. 방금 말씀
주셨다시피 삼성역은 좀 미래 가치가
굉장히 기대가 되는 지역이잖아요.
그래서 그 성격 자체가 다르다 보니까
좀 성향에 따라 좀 좋아하시는 것들도
좀 많이 다르신 거 같아요. 그래서
가장 많이 언급되는 또 지역인 거
같습니다. 그 단도지을 어디 사고
싶어요? 저는 삼성
그죠. 삼성역에서 어디 방향? GBC
인근이 이제 봉원사역이랑 삼성역 인근
고급 가장 인접해 있는 곳들 위주로
좀 찾아볼 거 같고요. 인근에 또
막상 살려고 찾아보면은 그렇게 살
만한 땅이 많지가 않다고 느껴져요.
코익스 건너편은 이제 GBC 개발하는
부지들이 투자하려고 보면은 굉장히 좀
볼륨이 큰 느낌이고 그 위쪽 땅은
일종 일반 주거 지역에 좀 언덕이 좀
많은 느낌에 투자할 만한 땅이 많지
않다고 느껴집니다. 그래서 그런 땅들
중에 좀 괜찮은 땅을 좀 찾아보면은
좋은 선택을 하실 수 있지 않을까라는
생각이 그러니까 이제 집일 수 있는
블록을 말씀하신 거죠. 네. 그
블록을 좀 우선해서 가장 인접해 있는
땅들 위주로 좀 찾아볼 것 같습니다.
약간 소신발언 해 되나요? 어. 네.
이게 지금 원래 계획은 100층
넘었잖아요.로드 타워보다 이제 높게
짓는 걸로 되는데 근데 이번에 이제
설계 변경 되면서 이제 세 개동으로
바뀌었잖아요. 아, 이거 제일
아쉬워요. 50층 이렇게 세 개동으로
바뀐게 전 진짜 너무 안타깝거든요.
네. 시그니엘 그 이상의 뭔가
상징성을 뛸 수 있을 만한 자리였는데
굉장히 그냥 센터필드 같이 마무리 된
느낌. 네. 사실 2014년도에
샀는데 아직까지 뭐 지금 그죠.
10년 넘게. 그러니까요. 그래서
저는 좀 개인적으로 너무 안타깝고
그리고 세계적으로 저는 서울이 되게
좋은 도시라고 생각을 하는데 내세울게
사실 빌딩이 많이 없는 거 같아요.
네. 뭐 롯데 타워가 일단 잘 있긴
하지만 그거를 뭔가 더 뛰어넘는
빌딩이 나올 법만 했는데 이게 좀
무산돼서 좀 개인적으로 아쉽긴
합니다. 그렇죠. 그리고 롯데타워가
송파에 있지만 그 강남 안에서도 뭔가
더 상체성을 뛸 수 있을 만한 건물이
나온다라고 하면 더 주목받을 수
있었을 것 같은데 네. 굉장히 아쉬운
부분인 거 같습니다. 그러니까요.
그래서 소신발 여기까지 하고 그래서
그쪽 부분도 괜찮은 거 같아요.
삼성역 그 밑에 부분. 아, 대치동
쪽으로 강남역은 어떻게 보시나요,
대표님? 강남역은 뭐 일단 지금 너무
좋은 상태긴 하지만 그 삼성력을 좀
좋게 보는 이유 중에 하나가 영동대로
이제 공원화되거든요. 네. 광화문
광장처럼. 네. 그래서 사람들이 거기
이제 걸어다니기 되게 좋을 거
같아요. 지하로 이제 다니고 그
위에는 이제 걸어다닐 수 있고.
강남구에 사실 그렇게 걸어다닐 수
있는 데가 없거든요. 그래서 아마
사람들이 그쪽으로 좀 많이 몰릴 거
같고 거기가 이제 그 광공판 이런게
많잖아요. 네네. 그래서 뭐 한국에
뭐 타임스케어를 만들겠다 뭐 이런
얘기도 있는데 뭐 지금 강남역도 너무
좋긴 하지만 향으로 생각하면 저도
똑같이 이제 삼성역 쪽이 더 좋지
않을까 이렇게 예상을 합니다. 정말
그 타임스퀘어 말씀 주셨는데 광고판도
많고 외국인들도 좀 많이 돌아다니다
보니까 갔을 때 또 굉장히 다른
느낌을 좀 받는 거 같아요. 그리고
강남역이랑 크게 다른 느낌 중에
하나가 강남역은 이제 테란로 업무
시설을 좀 기반으로 그냥 일반
오피스가 굉장히 좀 잘 자리를 잡고
있는 느낌인 반면에 삼성은 고급
비즈니스가 좀 자리를 잡고 있고 잡아
나가고 있는듯한 느낌을 받습니다.
제가 직접 뭐 상관 나가서 소비를
하더라도 강남역보다는 삼성역단가가 좀
많이 높은 느낌이에요. 프라이빗한
상점들도 많이 있고 고급 비즈니스나
그런 업무를 보시는 분들 타겟으로 좀
식당이 형성되어 있어서 그런 거
같아서 확실히 상권 색이 좀 많이
다른 거 같습니다. 그리고 약간
우수갯 소리로 그런 얘기도
하더라고요. 이제 강남의 사혹가
아니라 삼성역에 사오기다. 아 제가
좀 찾아와 보니까 강남역 1평균 유동
인구가 한 60만 명이 된다고
하더라고요. 삼성역은 그 절반이 나는
30만 명 정도 된다라고 하는데
어쨌든 뭐 언제 들어올지 모르겠지만
교통 호재가 삼성역 쪽으로 다 몰려
있잖아요. 그런 좀 교통이 개발이
되고 뭐 광역 버스들 들어오고 하면은
그 유동 인구가 맞춰져서 그렇게 좀
크게 자리를 잡지 않을까라고 생각을
합니다. 어찌됐든 그 GBC에 있는
그 인력들이 그 오피스 수요도 되게
많잖아요. 그래서 저는 상권도 되게
좀 탄탄할 거라고 생각하거든요.
그래서 강남역도 실제로 보면 그
삼성에서 근무하시는 분이 많아요.
아, 물론 이제 매부에서도 많이
오지만 뭔가 주변에 그렇게 큰
오피스가 있다라는 거는 되게 큰
장점이 있지 않을까? 네. 이렇게
생각을 합니다. 그래서 오늘
강남역이랑 삼성역 상권에 대해서 좀
얘기를 했는데 제가 다음번 빌사남이
간다는 제가 강남역이 직접 가서 한번
현장 분위기를 다시 한번 잡아보도록
하겠습니다. 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요. 어 빌딩은 역시
불산나 불산나